wir haben schon heiß diskutiert und es
geht gleich weiter wie traurig
ja
deutschland wird unternehmer immer
unattraktiver
eine neue umfrage ergab dass 15 prozent
der deutschen in erwägung ziehen ins
ausland auszuwandern ich als
unternehmerin muss mittlerweile gestehen
dass ich das sehr gut verstehen kann
denn nicht nur die derzeitige oder seit
zwei jahren bestehende corona politik
und die korona maßnahmen machen sich und
unternehmer scheer unmöglich noch
wirtschaftlich zu arbeiten
auch unsere bürokratie die ins
unendliche geht dieses steuersystem ich
sag nur zehn steuerberater 10
steuererklärungen machen dass
wirtschaftlicher arbeiten für uns
unternehmer mit freude zunehmend
schwerer ein ganz anderer punkt ist noch
die digitalisierung in deutschland wo
wir wirklich auf einem absoluten
rückständigen punkt im moment angekommen
sind wodurch wir wirklich in vielen
bereichen nicht mehr vorwärts kommen
rohstoffmangel steigende strompreise die
wir gerade diskutiert haben behindern
das wirtschaftliche fortkommen und
führen dazu dass ich als unternehmerin
tatsächlich über nachdenken ob nicht
andere standorte mittlerweile
attraktiver sind und es macht mich
herzen eigentlich traurig
kann ich gut verstehen und ich glaube
sie haben wichtigen punkt weil all das
was wir uns auch in der politik
vornehmen wir wollen deutschland
klimaneutral gestalten wir wollen mehr
soziale gerechtigkeit das funktioniert
ja alles nur mit einer starken
wirtschaft irgendjemand muss ja das
ganze wirtschaft muss das ganze
finanzieren aber die themen die sie
angesprochen haben da hat sich glaube
ich die ampel im koalitionsvertrag schon
einiges vorgenommen stichwort fachkräfte
wir wollen jetzt ein echtes
einwanderungsgesetz dass auch
deutschland attraktiv macht für
qualifizierte fachkräfte gewonnen
gleichzeitig die hürden für geflüchtete
in den arbeitsmarkt abbauen damit ihr
nicht zum nichtstun verdammt werden
stichwort energie wir werden die
eeg-umlage abschaffen auf den strompreis
ist auch wieder für unternehmen gut
stichwort planungsbeschleunigungsgesetz
strukturprojekte schneller realisiert
werden wir wollen in die digitalisierung
investieren und wir schaffen es super
abschreibungen das unternehmen auch
anreize haben in klimafreundlich und
digitale technologien zu investieren das
heißt das thema wir haben wir die
wirtschaft in schwung spielt für die
ampel eine große rolle das klingt alles
immer so supertoll das problem ist nur
auf politischer ebene mag das alles so
ein aber ich lebe in der realität und
arbeit in schottland und erwirtschafte
unmengen an steuern und kann nur sagen
das funktioniert ja alles und ich
wirklich am ende des tages nämlich so
aus dass wir fast kein mittelstand mehr
haben ist für uns mittelständler die mit
wie ich meine praxis inhaberin versucht
sich irgendwie durch diesen dschungel
durch zu navigieren mehr damit
beschäftigt bin das bürokratische zu
erledigen oder meine steuererklärung
über monate hinweg zu machen
vorauszahlungen zu machen zu stemmen
mitarbeiter in quarantäne zu schicken
wieder rauszuholen wolltest doch negativ
also in einem völligen chaos existieren
muss um mich da auf weiter flur oft
ziemlich alleingelassen fühlen und durch
die steuerprogression kommt man ja
mittelstand auch gar nicht an so einem
punkt wie jetzt große unternehmen die
sicherlich von solchen maßnahmen wieder
profitieren können dass man wirklich
auch mal vermögen schaffen kann für mich
ist es zum beispiel in bayern nicht
möglich aus meiner hart erarbeiteten
kraft also als einzelunternehmen am ende
des tages mir ein eigenheim einfach so
zu leisten also es ist stellenweise sehr
demotivierend woher soll man jetzt auch
jungen start-up-unternehmen zum beispiel
noch sagen hey seid euch im standort
deutschland anwalt das lohnt sich hier
also da gibt es mittlerweile einfach
attraktivere standorte und ich finde das
ziemlich gefährlich für unsere zukunft
sagen tut tut die ampel genug um
unternehmerinnen und unternehmer
wirklich auch zu fördern und zu stützen
sie sprachen gerade einmal das thema die
eeg umlage an abschaffung da muss ich
ehrlich gesagt selbst lachen denn wir
wissen glaube ich hier alle am tisch
wenn der stromkunde sie nicht mehr zahlt
dann zahlt der steuerzahler die eeg
umlage muss ja irgendwie finanziert wenn
das heißt frau rehbein zeit
möglicherweise höhere steuern oder das
geld was für steuersenkungen da wäre
kann nicht in steuersenkungen gehen die
ig umlage ist die ökostrom umlage ich
erkläre es einfach noch mal ganz kurz
genau und die ampel hat gesagt sie will
sich streichen hat sich schon leicht
gesenkt zu jahresbeginn will sie
generell abschaffen das heißt der
strompreis wird sinken aber das geld das
bekommen die strom hersteller ja
trotzdem das kommt dann dosen mehr von
den stromkunden sondern eben von den
steuerzahlern das heißt dass rechte
tasche linke tasche und das ist glaube
ich blöd wenn man das so als trick
verkauft und als entlastung das ist
natürlich für viele leute entlastung
also beispielsweise für geringverdiener
für rentner für schüler und studenten
damit ihr unternehmen
so lud akw nicht die steuern aber den es
ja ja und es gehen da habe ich keine
lust mehr zu sondern gehe ich lieber
woanders sehen denn es kann nicht sein
dass wir überhaupt nicht berücksichtigen
bei den ganzen stadt wie steam man dafür
tun muss ein politiker sagt erhöhen ja
nicht die steuern höher
wir haben jetzt ja die partei habe
allein aber 301 steuern erhöhen die fdp
hat in der regierung durchgesetzt dass
es keine steuererhöhungen gibt keine
neuen steuern keine erhöhung bestehender
steuern keine vermögenssteuer was auch
gerade für unternehmer wichtig ist keine
erhöhung der einkommensteuer was für
personengesellschaften wichtiges wir
reden ja nicht nur vom großkonzern
sondern viele mittelständler zahlen ja
einfach die einkommensteuer das heißt
wir haben wir haben keine mehrbelastung
wir schaffen an vielen stellen zum
beispiel ich habe es gerade dargelegt
super abschreibungsmöglichkeiten anreize
um zu ihnen aber er ist ein verschieben
die sache ist wenn ich mir also ein
absoluter versteht nicht verloren aber
macht die ampelkarte hier kommt er gut
die ampel ist seit zwei monaten im amt
da muss man auch mal sagen also heißt
wir können nicht die ganze liste die
ganze wunschliste die hagener referiert
hat na da haben wir jetzt fehle dafür
zeit das zu machen mich so schnell wie
möglich das ganze und was ich denke was
ich auch ändern muss es sind im klima im
land was gründung fördert ja viele
jugendliche im land die möchten lieber
job im öffentlichen dienst kann ich
verstehen erst mal sicher kommt das geld
pünktlich und so weiter aber wir müssen
das eben fördern über schülerfirmen über
die möglichkeit einfach zu gründen auch
immer von einem tag eine firma zu
gründen ich habe selber drei firmen
gegründet also ich kann das auch
nachvollziehen und weiß wie schwierig
das ist eben erst mal alles beieinander
hat von steuernummer bis umsatzsteuer
adidas mit der bank geklagt hatten der
gründung und beim notar und so weiter da
müssen wir wesentlich besser und
schneller werden und eben jugendliche
motivieren dass es sich lohnt in
deutschland zu gründen dazu gehört aber
auch hausaufgaben machen es gibt überall
internet lehrer ein mobilfunknetz ja ja
und überall hinkommen tut man auch
bessere mobilität also da muss ich ein
stück weit wirklich zustimmten großes
problem ist wir haben seit geraumer zeit
einen ausbildungsplatz zu bieten wir
finden aber keinen geeigneten
auszubildenden tatsächlich weil entweder
man noch nicht mal als pünktlich zum
termin kommt der deutschen sprache nicht
mächtig ist mit zerrissenen jeans
ankommt mich dann
als chefin dann sagt das machen was
machst du eigentlich hier
was machst du ewig sind na ja also ich
wäre rein theoretisch eine chefin aber
jetzt hat auch noch mehr also dass also
die realität in deutschland sieht ganz
anders aus als das politisch immer so
nennt klingen sternchen die strenge
chefin überhaupt okay da haben sie jetzt
die chance einmal hier werbung zu machen
ja also wir haben einen ausbildungsplatz
die medizinischen fachangestellten zu
bieten und suchen qualifizierte
hochmotivierte menschen und junge
menschen die nur freude haben in diesem
land mit anzupacken und eine tolle nacht
praxis zu arbeiten ja auch die chefin
auch hier verspricht sich ist nicht
streng sondern sie ist sehr engagiert
und sie als merkel ja
ich bin ja ich bin ja voll bei ihnen ich
vermute mal wenn sie meine wunschliste
aufschreiben zehn punkte die politik
machen sollte würden neuen halb davon
sagen finde ich als fdp gut können wir
umsetzen wir sind aber jetzt mal in der
regierung mit verschiedenen parteien und
wir kommen auch aus einer bestimmten
situationen die letzten 16 jahre merkel
nist viele sachen liegen geblieben die
wie jetzt gerade an hausaufgaben
abzuräumen haben sind sie ein bisschen
gnädig mit uns lassen sie uns mal
zumindest ein paar monate zeit das ganze
anzufangen schwierig wie beim beten
hilft auch keine gnädig wenn ich nicht
irgendwem eine steuervorauszahlung
abgeben da muss ich schon muss ich schon
strafzinsen rasant zwar ab der ersten
stunde wurst zu spät kommt mit uns
bürgern ist ja auch keiner gnädig für
also nicht so dass er alle drohanrufen
hat sie dann kann ich hab ein problem
wie das sind ja nah beisammen hat er ja
wir tun ja schon einiges wird um
verständnis dass wir nicht alles du bist
gar nicht ihre schuld dass er probleme
die über viele jahrzehnte schon ist aber
der eindruck den sie oder das was sie
schildern und der eindruck der sich
glaube ich ergibt bei vielen auch bei
journalisten die das politische
geschehen betrachten ist doch dass das
geld immer er verteilt wird beim thema
wohnkosten zu es ist es genauso jetzt
gibt's den für ungefähr 15 millionen
bürger das mag auch jedem gegönnt sein
aber man tut so nach dem motto also wenn
dieses geld vom himmel fallen würde und
das ist natürlich nicht vom himmel wir
haben leute ihr ganzes leben arbeiten
die nach einer rente rauskommen unter
hartz 4 also wir haben einfach ein super
schlechtes lohnniveau und also
funktioniert auch
wir haben ein super schlechtes niveau
und ich habe in meinem wahlkreis
verdienen 35 prozent der menschen also
deutlich unter dem mindestlohn er unter
zehn euro also durch den aktuellen
mindestlohn und es ist so dass bei mir
knapp 50 prozent der bevölkerung im
wahlkreis unter 1500 euro netto
mitnehmen nach hause und nochmals 40
prozent davon unter 1200 euro
finanzieren sie da von dem manchmal ein
klo
ich würde gerne etliche arbeitsplätze
schaffen ich würde gern ich hätte auch
kapazitäten noch mehr menschen als ich
würde wahnsinnig gern tun ich kann es
mir als unternehmerin gar nicht leisten
weil sie leben lohnnebenkosten sind so
hoch wenn ich meine mitarbeiter und ich
habe wirklich zweiter die sind exzellent
und den würde ich so gerne eine enorme
lohnerhöhung geben das kostet mich aber
zunehmen so viel dass die 50 euro mehr
auf dem konto haben das ist doch auch
schon absurd aber als angehöriger
sozusagen der mittelschicht würde ich
mal sagen ich fühle ich mich von der
politik vergessen denn mit müller
schauen auf den mindestlohn jetzt wird
die minijob verdienstgrenze erhöht das
kann man auch alles machen ist
vielleicht auch alles richtig nur was
ist denn jetzt zum beispiel mit mir so
als angehörige der mittelschicht so
manche haben können sie organ zu kümmern
und so aber magath die hälfte davon weg
gleichzeitig kann ich irgendwie
förderung bei an aber ich das einmal
doch mal sagen gehabt ich habe auch das
leben ganz kurz immer wieder heißt
kostenlos im kindergarten das stimmt
nicht hält da ist nicht kostenlos wer
zahlt denn es gibt nichts kostenlos juli
verschieben nur gebühren verschieben und
möglicherweise zahlen die bayern herr
hagen und frau rehbein zahlen dafür dass
mag ehrenwert sein zahlen dafür dass in
mecklenburg verbot kinder gebührenfreie
kindergarten können es gibt in diesem
land nichts kosten seinem er immer zeit
irgendjemand da natürlich zahlt am ende
sind wir am tisch unsere zuschauerinnen
und zuschauer was ganz toll ist aber das
müssen wir uns glaube ich immer und
jeder politiker muss sich das
vergegenwärtigen nichts ist umsonst und
wenn der politiker wie hinschauen sagt
das haben wir wieder gemacht wie gerne
schröder wir haben eine firma gerettet
holzmann und dann hat mich eher die
firma gerettet sondern haben die
deutschen steuerzahler die firma
gerettet denen gehört er dann aber eher
gaiser konkret gefragt was ist für ihn
drin also sparer pauschbetrag wird
profitieren sie direkt von
ausbildungsfreibetrag bedeutet wenn sie
kindern profitieren so von eeg umlage
profitieren so von die rentenbeiträge
sind künftig von der steuer voll
abzugsfähig profitieren so von also
jetzt mal vier punkte wo sie konkret als
angehöriger der mittelschicht von
profitieren ich hätte auch gerne mehr da
wird auch gerne aber es stimmt nicht es
stimmt nicht dass für die mittelschicht
nichts getan wird aber ich mir auch mehr
beziehung mit mir werden sie auf die
vermögenspreise also insbesondere die
immobilienpreise eine riesen problem ich
habe nicht das gefühl dass die politik
das in den griff bekommt das heißt da
werden menschen mit einer ganzen
generation eint eine lebenschance
genommen die noch für meine eltern
generation eigentlich relativ
selbstverständlich da aber dass man
natürlich irgendwie ins eigenheim kann
oder zumindest die chance darauf hat
viele haben jetzt nicht mal mehr
theoretisch die chance das irgendwie zu
fühlen uns hier und irgendwie ab so tina
und wenn es erst darf dennoch
erbschaftssteuer zahlen auf das bereits
schon versteuerte vermögen seiner eltern
also reden wir über den kern des
problems und das ist unser völlig
absurdes verworrenes steuersystem